R
SILENCE ON THE LAWSUIT FILED
AGAINST HER BY THREE FORMER
DANCERS WHO CLAIM THEY WERE
SUBJECT TODAY A HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENT AND HARASSMENT.
THE CLAIM NAMING HER PRODUCTION
COMPANY AND CAPTAIN OF HER DANCE
TEAM.
IT SAYS THE DANCERS WERE EXPOSED
TO OUTINGS WHERE NUDITY AND
SEXUALITY WERE A FOCAL POINT.
IT ALLEGES THAT LIZZO CALLED OUT
ONE OF THE PLAINTIFFS FOR HER
WEIGHT GAIN AFTER ACCUSING THE
DANCER OF NOT BEING COMMITTED TO
HER ROLE.
LIZZO IS KNOWN, OF COURSE, FOR
HER UPLIFTING MESSAGES AND
ADVOCACY FOR BODY POSITIVITY.
>> I AM NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
PLEASE EVERYBODY WITH MY OUTWARD
APPEARANCE.
SOMEONE'S ALWAYS GONNA HAVE A
CRITIQUE, NEGATIVITY TO SAY
ABOUT ME.
ALL THAT MATTERS IS WHAT I THINK
ABOUT IT.
>> NOW, AFTER WHAT HAD BEEN A
NOTABLY LENGTHY SILENCE, SHE
RESPONDED TO THE LAWSUIT ON
INSTAGRAM WRITING, IN PART, THE
SENSATIONALIZED STUDIES ARE
COMING FROM FORMER EMPLOYEES WHO
PUBLICLY ADMITTED THEY WERE TOLD
THEIR BEHAVIOR ON TOUR WAS
INAPPROPRIATE AND
UNPROFESSIONAL.
I TAKE MY MUSIC AND PERFORMANCES
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY I ONLY WANT TO PUT OUT
THE BEST ART THAT REPRESENTS ME
AND MY FANS WITH PASSION COMES
HARD WORK AND HIGH STANDARDS.
JOINING US NOW ARE THE THREE
DANCERS, CRYSTAL WILLIAMS,
ARIANA DAVIS AND NOEL RODRIGUEZ
ALONG WITH THEIR ATTORNEY.
CRYSTAL, THE RESPONSE THAT YOU
HAVE TO THE RESPONSE FROM LIZZO
AFTER THE SILENCE FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OTIME?
>> YEAH, I WANT TO SAY THAT
READING IT JUST KINDA FURTHERED
MY, LIKE, DISAPPOINTMENT IN
REGARDS TO THE SITUATION, JUST
BECAUSE THE FACTS ARE THE FACTS.
WHAT WE EXPERIENCED AND WHAT WE
WITNESSED IS ABSOLUTELY WHAT
HAPPENED.
THERE IS NOTHING SENSATIONALIZED
ABOUT IT.
SO ALL THAT I CAN HOPE IS THAT
PEOPLE FOCUS MORE SO ON THE
FACTS RATHER THAN THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION.
>> ARIANA, AT WHAT POINT DID YOU
REALIZE THAT WHAT YOU WERE
EXPERIENCING, ALLEGEDLY
EXPERIENCED, WAS NOT NORMAL?
>> I -- IT'S HARD TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE, AS THIS WAS MY
FIRST PROFESSIONAL JOB, I WAS
TOLD BY THE DANCE CAPTAIN AND,
YOU KNOW, JUST -- IT'S THIS
THING IN THE DANCE INDUSTRY THAT
YOU HAVE TO, YOU KNOW, SHUT UP
AND, YOU KNOW, TAKE WHATEVER YOU
GET AND JUST BE GRATEFUL FOR
WHATEVER CRUMBS YOU GET AS A
DANCER.
SO A LOT OF THINGS THAT WERE
GOING ON, IT TOOK ME A REALLY
LONG TIME TO FIGURE OUT THAT IT
WAS WRONG.
IT TOOK ME, ACTUALLY, UNTIL
LEAVING THE CAMP THAT I FIGURED
OUT THAT EVERYTHING THAT WAS --
WENT ON WAS BAD, BECAUSE I JUST
CHALKED IT UP TO, LIZZO MIGHT
ABDIVA OR THIS IS JUST THE
INDUSTRY, THIS IS WHAT WE GO
THROUGH.
I THINK THAT I HAD INK WLINGS.
LIKE, I WOULD BE ON THE PHONE
WITH MY MOM ALL DAY AND BE,
LIKE, JUST COMPLAINING ABOUT
THIS DISRESPECT AND THE
TREATMENT AND THE HUMILIATION.
I MEAN, ME PERSONALLY, LOOKING
AT THE RESPONSE FROM LIZZO, WAS
SO DISHEARTENING, BECAUSE SHE
WAS THERE.
SHE WAS THERE.
AND TO FIX YOUR HAND TO WRITE ON
A PIECE OF PAPER THAT YOU DON'T
BELIEVE -- THAT YOU DISCREDIT
EVERYTHING WE'RE SAYING IS
INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATING.
THE FACTS ARE THE FACTS, LIKE
CRYSTAL SAID.
WAS I PRESSURED TO TOUCH A NUDE
PERFORMER?
YES.
WAS I BROUGHT INTO A PRIVATE
MEETING WHERE I WAS KIND OF
INTERROGATED ABOUT MY PERSONAL
MATTERS AND ENDED UP HAVING TO
SHARE VERY PERSONAL, PERSONAL
THINGS ABOUT MYSELF, REGARDING
MY WEIGHT?
YES.
I MEAN, THE LIST GOES ON.
WERE WE PRESSURED TO DO AN
EXCRUCIATINGLY LONG REHEARSAL
THAT TURNED INTO A REAUDITION
FOR THE JOB THAT WE ALREADY
BOOKED BECAUSE, APPARENTLY, WE
WEREN'T DOING ENOUGH?
YES, THAT IS TRUE.
DURING THAT REAUDITION PROCESS,
WAS I UNDER THE IMPRESSION IF I
LEFT THE STAGE, I WOULD BE
FIRED?
YES.
DID I, UNFORTUNATELY, GO TO THE
BATHROOM ON MYSELF ON ONE STAGE,
BECAUSE I WAS SOTERRIFIED?
YES.
THERE IS -- IN A COURT OF LAW, I
DON'T KNOW -- I'M NOT A LAWYER.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING.
BUT I KNOW IF YOU ASK SOMEONE TO
TELL THE TRUTH, THESE THINGS
WILL COME OUT OF HER MOUTH.
IF YOU HAVE TO SAY YES OR NO TO
THESE QUESTIONS, SHE HAS TO SAY
YES, BECAUSE THEY ARE TRUE.
THERE WAS MULTIPLE WITNESSES.
AND I -- I DON'T APPRECIATE THE
DISCREDIT OF OUR FEELINGS AND
OUR EXPERIENCES AND OUR TRAUMAS.
>> UNDERSTOOD.
JOELLE, YOU ALLEGE THAT LIZZO
INTENDED TO HIT YOU AT ONE POINT
AFTER YOU -- SORRY.
KNOW AM.
INTENDED TO HIT YOU ONE POINT
AFTER YOU RESIGNED.
DO YOU REALLY THINK SHE WAS
GOING TO RESORT OR COULD RESORT
TO PHYSICAL VIOLENCE?
>> YEAH, I DO.
I DO.
I MEAN, THE FACTS OF THAT WERE
THAT SHE ACTUALLY BALLED UP HER
FIST LIKE THIS TO ME.
SHE STARTED CRACKING HER
KNUCKLES AND SHE WAS, LIKE,
YOU'RE SO F-ING LUCKY THAT,
BASICALLY, I AM NOT GONNA HIT
YOU.
AND THAT, YOU KNOW, I WAS IN
SHOCK WATCHING HER DO THAT AND
CRACKING HER KNUCKLES AND ACTING
AS IF SHE WAS GOING TO COME
AFTER ME.
FOR A SECOND I WAS, LIKE, I
DON'T THINK SHE'S GONNA DO THAT.
THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
THE FACT THAT ONE OF HER
DANCERS -- ALL OF US WERE
PRESENT.
ALL OF THE DANCERS WERE PRESENT
FOR EVERY -- MOSTLY ALL OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS.
AND IN THAT MEETING THAT WE HAD
WHERE SHE GOT PHYSICAL AND WAS
ABOUT TO ASSAULT ME, HER BEST
FRIEND, WHO IS ALSO ONE OF THE
DANCERS, HAD TO JUMP OUT OF THE
COUCH AND PHYSICALLY HOLD HER
BACK FROM COMING AND HITTING ME.
SO, YES, I DO BELIEVE THAT IF
SHE WASN'T HELD BACK BY THAT
DANCER, SHE WOULD HAVE HIT ME.
>> WHAT YOU DESCRIBE THERE,
THERE IS CLEARLY NOT ONLY DO YOU
BELIEVE YOU HAVE WITNESSES, BUT
POTENTIALLY OTHER PEOPLE YOU
WOULD THINK WOULD WANT TO BE A
PART OF A LAWSUIT.
TO SOME DEGREE, I WOULD DIRECT
THAT YOUR WAY, IN TERMS OF DO
YOU BELIEVE MORE PEOPLE WILL
JOIN?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO WORKED
WITH THESE THREE WOMEN, WHO
EXPERIENCED THE SAME THINGS,
THAT WOULD LIKE TO JOIN THIS
LAWSUIT, OR SUE ON THEIR OWN
ACCOUNT IN THE FUTURE?
>> 100%.
PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY COME ON
SOCIAL MEDIA TO SUPPORT OUR
CLIENTS.
PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY REACHED OUT
TO MY OFFICE THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA.
100%.
I BELIEVE MORE PEOPLE WILL COME
FORWARD, IF NOT HERE WHERE WE
ARE IN LOS ANGELES, BUT IN NEW
YORK, AND WE RECEIVED OTHER